okay so I told you at the start of this
week that if the recent polling trends
continued by the end of this week or
maybe by early next week Joe Biden could
be out of first place in the Democratic
primary Bernie Sanders could be all the
way down to fourth place that was if the
recent trends continued and they have
not
okay the trends have reversed both Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders have recovered
a little bit of that support that
they've recently lost in the last 10 to
14 days or so both Kamala Harris and
Elizabeth Warren who have been the big
gainers since the over the last 10 days
or since the democratic debate have
leveled off so as of now Joe Biden is
still in first place although certainly
by a smaller margin than he has been
Bernie Sanders is back into second place
but just just just barely while Kamala
Harris and Elizabeth Warren are sort of
steady in third and fourth places
respectively now what I want to deal
with today is I want to think about if
and when should the candidates polling
under 1% abandon the race if and when
should the candidates polling under 2%
get out of this race there are lots of
them okay according to the Real Clear
Politics average of recent polls there
are currently nine candidates polling
under 1%
those are delaney tim ryan marianne
williamson kirsten gillibrand
Bennett and Hickenlooper Bill DeBlasio
jay Inslee and Bullock nine candidates
currently polling under 1% now you'll
notice that Eric's wall well is not on
the list he was at the debate a week or
two ago but he ended his presidential
run earlier this week recognizing he's
getting absolutely no traction
whatsoever something some of the others
it's unclear whether they recognize or
not or at least it's unclear whether
they care so that's the 9-under 1% in
addition there are four more candidates
polling between one and two percent
those are Amy Klobuchar Andrew yang
Julian Castro and Tulsi Gabbard and then
just just just barely eking out two
percent our Cory Booker at 2.1 and bado
Rourke with 2.6 now a few thoughts about
this before we move
and really dig into what is it that
these candidates should be doing it's
kind of a tragedy that bado is ahead of
who leon castro bado
imploded in the presidential debate in
the Democratic primary debate a couple
of weeks ago who Leon Castro was
actually quite strong but bado is still
slightly ahead that's unfortunate
number two similarly amy klobuchar was a
train wreck in that first debate while
kirsten gillibrand actually did pretty
well i don't agree with her on all
policy but just in evaluating debate
performance Gillibrand did significantly
better than Chloe char globish are
somehow ahead of Gillibrand but again
this is all like they're all polling so
little they're kind of all within the
margin of error in a sense so the
immediate question is how long should
these candidates stay in the race I am
for more candidates I am for more
choices I'm for more debate and more
dialogue and different ideas as part of
the primary process but I also want
there to be more depth in the debates
that can't happen when you have 20
candidates across two stages and
30-second rebuttals as the standard
format okay
so III do believe that we would in many
ways benefit from starting to trim the
field down we pulled our audience on
YouTube at youtube.com slash the david
pakman show slash community the question
was who should exit the Democratic
primary before the next debates at the
end of this month 7% of our audience say
everybody should stay in 48% want
everyone pulling under 5% to get out
which is very harsh 22% say everybody
under 2% should get out and 15% say
everyone under 1% should get out now
just as a thought experiment if
everybody under 5% got out today that
would leave only five candidates and
that includes Budaj
at exactly 5 percent and not a fraction
more it seems a bit aggressive to me at
this point in time we're still about a
year out from the convention but
certainly if you're still under 1% at
this point in time you have no shot I
would get out I think that the two
percenters could make the case for
staying in to this second debate
there's a good chance they'll be
eliminated by the requirements before
the third debate on September 12th and
13th anyway the next debate is at the
end of this month July 30 and 31 on CNN
a lot of these you know the the two
percenters many of them are going to be
gone before the third debate anyway
because they're simply not going to
qualify so as a reminder to make that
early September third debate candidates
need to have both at least 2% in four
different polls and a hundred and thirty
thousand unique donors as of right now
only Joe Biden Kamala Harris Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren and Pete Budaj
have met that criteria so this race will
be effectively smaller by September 12th
even if a lot of these candidates stay
in they're not going to be on that third
debate stage until unless things change
radically and potentially we will be
down to just one debate stage by
September 12th instead of having to do
it on two nights so let me know what you
think our audience at least on YouTube
an unscientific reflection merely of the
fraction of our nearly 700,000 YouTube
subscribers who chose to vote in this
poll say if you're under 5% you should
get out immediately that seems a little
bit aggressive but a lot of these folks
will be gone by September 12th let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and voting is still open on
the David Pakman show YouTube channel if
you want to cast your vote one of
today's sponsors is impeach the card
slap game you can't slap Donald Trump in
real life but you can slap them in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach impeach the card game is
awesome for parties or when you're
having a few drinks i've been playing it
with some friends of mine it combines
clever satire about the trump
administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
very lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and how much thought went
into the humor and the political
commentary impeach the cards slap game
is perfect if you're looking for
something fun and casual to do
with your politically minded friends or
family members it'll make a perfect gift
for anyone you know who has a sense of
humor about Donald Trump and when you go
to david pakman.com slash impeach not
only will you get 10% off the game you
can also get 10% off all of the other
hilarious clothing and accessories in
their online store t-shirts coffee mugs
tote bags featuring funny political
cartoons about trump that you can't find
anywhere else get a super fun
witty gift for yourself or someone you
know whether it's impeach the cards slap
game or anything else in the gift shop
and get 10% off all of it when you go to
david pakman.com slash impeach